el Real Madrid volvió a pisar el césped
tras el partido contra el Valencia del
domingo que desató un huracán de
reacciones y debates sobre el racismo en
el fútbol dentro y fuera de España lo
hizo sin vinicius Junior víctima de los
recientes ataques racistas que fue baja
por unas molestias en la rodilla antes
de que empezara el derbi contra el Rayo
Vallecano la afición opinaba sobre el
tema es algo que predomina mucho en el
fútbol los insultos tanto de racismo
como de xenofobia de todo tipo y es algo
que no tendría que tener cabida en el
fútbol no se puede permitir eso en
ningún campo de fútbol da igual que sea
aquí en vallecas el Camp Nou de igual
aquí no creo poco animal o equipo y ya
está disfrutar lo que al final Pues mira
no le están insultando porque ser
racista España no es un país racista
está insultando porque es un jugador del
otro equipo le desconcentra le sacan del
partido juega mal pues ganan la gana la
partida Mientras que el martes hubo
varios detenidos y el Valencia recibió
una multa de 45.000 euros y se cerró de
temporalmente la grada del mestalla en
la que se dieron los insultos en España
prima la impunidad ante estos actos
nunca se ha suspendido un partido ni ha
habido condenas Pese a que el código
penal español establece penas de hasta
dos años de cárcel en Casos de racismo o
xenofobia no se asignada para castigar
Así que parece que es un problema muy
estructural y que no ha sido resuelto Yo
creo que con la gente que está
insultando porque les corte la entrada
sería y así por la gente va aprendiendo
y no lo haría el partido no puede
continuar cuando hay estas faltas de
respeto a los jugadores sean del equipo
que sean quedan un par de jornadas en
esta recta final de la liga veremos si
este parón ayuda a tener un debate
sosegado y a implementar medidas
contundentes o si la pausa en la
competición diluye la conversación y el
problema vuelve a caer en el olvido